[Music]
with the new Enterprise Plus Edition you
can now run your business critical high
performance workloads faster and with
more availability on cloud SQL you have
a SAS application running on let's say
MySQL serving up millions of
transactions bringing in that Revenue
it's clear you need high performance and
minimizing downtime as Paramount because
we all know time means money but more
importantly you don't want to lose your
users trust you also know you're going
to need to scale as your business grows
and changes this is where Enterprise
Plus comes in it's a new flavor of cloud
SQL you get the power of cloud SQL a
managed service that makes it easy to
set up operate and scale the MySQL and
postgres databases you already love and
adds in new features new blazing fast
performance low downtime maintenance and
extended data protection for your most
critical workloads Enterprise Plus
delivers new capabilities in three main
areas performance availability and data
protection
to serve the most demanding applications
Enterprise Plus Edition provides three
times Improvement in read throughput
over Enterprise Cloud SQL with the new
data cache in MySQL which is coming for
postgres soon
rights are also more performant with two
times the throughput and two times lower
transaction commit latency now you're
Off to the Races
if you need larger machines to scale up
even more Enterprise Plus also now
allows you to create instances up to 128
vcpus
Enterprise Plus Edition has near zero
downtime maintenance and can deliver
four nines of availability it leverages
temporary read replicas with the latest
bits and seamlessly shifts your primary
instance so your application can
continue to operate without disruption
and you don't have to decide between
installing latest updates and disrupting
users
when you need to recover from disasters
like accidental data deletion you can
use cloud sql's point in time recovery
capabilities Enterprise Plus Edition
will provide up to 35 days worth of log
storage at no additional cost a must for
regulated Industries and SAS customers
don't just take my word for it we've
been talking to folks about it here's
what they have to say about it
Cloud SQL Enterprise Plus gives you all
the value you already get with Cloud SQL
Enterprise adding in higher performance
and availability and we're not done yet
you'll see more capabilities coming to
both Cloud SQL Enterprise and Enterprise
Plus additions in the next few months
to learn more about Cloud SQL Enterprise
Plus Edition check out the launch blog
links in the description below and try
it out yourself it's easy to get started
you can create a new instance running on
Enterprise Plus via the Google Cloud
console gcloud API or terraform thanks
for watching
foreign
[Music]